a new report from axios reveals that the
biden administration has released
50 000 illegal aliens into the united
states without any court date
the officials just told them to
voluntarily check back in
with ice agents later on and you're
going to be shocked to hear this
turns out the vast majority of these
illegal aliens
failed to show up to the deportation
authority can you imagine
yes foreign nationals get to flout our
laws
roam wherever they please and breathe
the sweet era of freedom
but you the american citizen cannot
especially once the cdc's new mask
demands go into effect over the coming
days
some americans are calling on biden to
free cuba i'm calling on biden to free
the united states i'm michael knowles
that's the mike when all show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from andrew shelley
who is referring to that cop who said he
was called all sorts of racist slurs by
the
trump people at the capitol he provided
no evidence of course of this and we've
seen no evidence
and so andrew says hold on a second if
we've been living in a totally and
completely systemically racist society
for all
for all of time why then do the black
police officers declare that in their
entire life they have never been called
the n-word
until the capital event yes this is true
this is one of the problems
with uh making trump the root of all
evil in the world
is that the left is simultaneously
arguing that america is this terrible
rotten place and it's always been evil
and it's always been terrible
and making the argument that trump is
this unique threat to the country now
the country has always been evil right
so
no it's no big deal that trump's come
along or trump is the unique threat to
our democracy because our country's so
wonderful and good and he's destroying
our constitution but you just told me
that you hate our democracy and our
constitution
doesn't hold together very well you know
in times
of chaos like this it's good to have a
tangible physical asset
which is why you ought to check out acre
gold inflation is spiking people want
an asset that holds value well you know
what does that
great hedge against inflation physical
gold but michael you say
i just don't have the money to lay out
for physical gold it's
physical gold is expensive calm down pal
what if i told you
that you could start investing in
physical gold for as little as 30
dollars a month you're a liar michael
don't call me a liar come on i'm talking
about acre gold acre gold
will allow you to subscribe to their
gold bars for as low as 30
a month then when your gold stash
reaches the price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house acre has also introduced a
new 100
a month subscription to a 5 gram gold
bar if you want to up the ante a little
bit
acre keeps you updated every month and
then once you hit that threshold they
will ship acre gold to your house
it'll be neat discreet in your hands
it's a fantastic hedge you're seeing
spikes on gas
lumber food prices do it today you'll
thank me later get a goal dot com slash
knowles that is the url start investing
in physical gold today
make sure you go to that url because
acres giving away a gold bar to qualify
for the giveaway tweeter post why you
should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre
that's getacregold.com
knowles thank you aker gold for
supporting the show so on the topic of
of
the cdc and of freeing america i've just
received a memo from my social media
team here at the daily wire
they have gone through all of the new
rules on facebook
to determine what we are and are not
allowed to say so i just want this to be
clear right at the top
because i don't want there to be any
confusion
i will not it pursuant to facebook's new
guidelines
i will certainly not imply that the
return of the mask mandates indicates
that the vaccines are
not effective why would i imply that
you're saying that just because now
we're going back to the old masks after
so many people have received the vaccine
that that would imply that the vaccines
are not
who who would ever imply such a thing
surely not i
sir i can't say that the masks do not
work in order to say that i would have
to quote dr fauci from the beginning of
the pandemic so i wouldn't do that
i don't like quoting dr fauci i can't
say that children cannot get or spread
covid uh but i wouldn't i would never
say that anyway i i would point out that
children are at an
infinitesimally small risk of dying from
ko that are facing very very serious
uh consequences but i actually i
actually wouldn't say that won't say
that the masks are dirty
or could pose some risk to your health
again again i would have to quote dr
fauci in order to do that
from before dr fauci changed his mind so
certainly couldn't do that
uh do and i won't say that uh vaccinated
people can't
contract or spread covet well i
certainly i wouldn't do that because
obviously that's one of the issues that
we're all dealing with right now but
also
i'm not going to question the efficacy
of the vaccines so
i'm not i'm not going to say that the
vaccines protect you from getting
covered but i'm also
not going to say that the vaccines don't
protect you from getting coveted okay
what can i say i don't know it sounds
like i can't say a whole lot but i'm
glad that we cleared that up
i don't want there to be any confusion
about what we can or cannot say
according to our overlords the big tech
billionaires who work
very often directly with the federal
government
in a surveillance state in a liberal
blob that has now consumed every single
institution in the country
boy aren't you glad you live in the land
of the free aren't you we got to go send
in the marines to cuba right
we'll get to that in just a moment first
uh let's see how can i talk about the
cdc
i'll just tell you the facts here okay
the cdc
is now demanding that most of america
mask up again the cdc has these new
guidelines for areas of high
transmission even
where americans are fully vaccinated
they need to mask up
when you look at the
criteria that the cdc are talking about
for which counties should mask up
it actually comes to include over 60
percent of counties in the united states
as having high or substantial spread
according to the cdc guidelines and
therefore
they need to mask up again so most of
america according to our public health
agency
needs to mask up again by the way
illegal aliens can go wherever they want
most of the american citizens a clear
majority
of of counties in the united states i'll
be more specific need to mask up again
but our southern border is basically
non-existent
and we've had a milli at least a million
illegal aliens this year come across the
border
certainly on track for 2 million we had
188 000 come in just the month of june
alone
we've got biden the biden administration
releasing 50 000 illegal aliens without
a court date
how many of these guys are being tested
for coved or are taking the right
precautions
very very few of them so it would seem
to me
i can conclude from that that the biden
administration is not particularly
worried about the spread of covet
because if they were they'd close up the
southern border
but they are very concerned about
getting you to follow their capricious
and arbitrary guidelines
chip roy great u.s congressman
republican congressman
former chief of staff to senator ted
cruz
chip roy is pointing out the hypocrisy
here he's had enough of this there's a
crisis at the border and yet nancy
pelosi is now making
all of these vaccinated members of the
house
mask up again we have a crisis at our
border
and we're playing ftse with mass
mandates in the people's house
i mean it's absolutely absurd what this
body is doing the people's house it's an
embarrassment it's a mockery
and the american people are fed up they
want to go back to life they want to go
back to business they want to go back to
school without their children being
forced to wear masks
to be put in the corner to have mental
health issues and we're running around
here
and the speaker comes down here at 10
o'clock in the morning saying we got to
wear masks
in the people's house while we've got
thousands of people pouring across our
border
and democrats don't do a darn thing
about it heavily infected with cobit
we have the new york times okay today
what a mess you got a pause right there
before chip roy goes on
and makes i think a very important point
but you got to pause right there
because if you weren't watching marjorie
taylor green
who is this lightning rod for the left
she just walks into the frame she came
in late while chip roy was talking
completely unmasked sits down doesn't
care that's really great
so chip roy goes on and makes a point
that could get him kicked off of
facebook
we have people infected with covet
coming around our southern border into
texas
and you all put masks masks
up front here here on the people's house
we got to go around and see okay we
can't come to the floor i can't execute
my constitutional duty
unless i wear a mask which is it
vaccines or masks
do the vaccines work or they don't work
do the maths work so they don't work
i'd like to know which it is i'd like dr
fauci to come down and answer a single
question
about natural immunity if you've been
infected with a
virus do you have immunity or are they
just going to go around poking people
saying you must take a vaccine oh but
sorry the vaccine doesn't work you must
wear a mask
this institution is a sham and we should
adjourn and shut this place down
amen chip now you'll notice chip roy
said something here that according to
the new facebook guidelines
could and again it'll be so arbitrary
and capricious
could get him kicked off of facebook or
get a content strike against him or
something like that
and by the way all of these politicians
have very large facebook pages because
this is the public square and that is
how they campaign what chip roy said is
or what he what he implied but he
basically said it outright
is that if they're if the cdc is
requiring us all to mask up again and
pelosi and all the rest of them are
going along with it
then it that suggests that the vaccines
do not work particularly well because
he's saying if the vaccines worked
then you wouldn't need to wear the masks
now i want to be i'm being so specific
with my language facebook pay close
attention
i am not i'm being really nice here i'm
not even dealing with the point that
chip made the very
interesting and good point the chip made
i'm dealing with
what that means what it means
that some billionaire in silicon valley
named mark zuckerberg hired a bunch of
punk
tyrants who are now going to go channel
by channel
and say no u.s representative you can't
say that
no member of congress you can't say that
forget about chip roy
they did this to trump in january no
duly elected sitting president of the
united states
you can't say that because i
either some apparatchik at facebook or
twitter or google or or one of the
surveillance tech billionaires
themselves
because they say that you can't say that
as i point out in my book which i do
think becomes
scarier and scarier every day how true
this has become speechless
if you control speech in a republic such
as ours
you control the political system because
speech is politics and politics of
speech we govern one another
by persuasion and deliberation
right now a very small number of people
who have all of your data and know
everything about you
but who have crucially never appeared on
a ballot you've never elected them
they are controlling all of your speech
including the speech of your elected
representatives including the speech
of your presidents
scientists have a big credibility
problem
it's not just the scientists it's the
scientists and then the public health
experts who are half scientist
and half politician the health part is
the science the public part is
political and it's the politicians then
who
use the experts as cover i'm talking
about pelosi
and all of the rest of them they have a
credibility problem
this isn't just me saying this this
isn't just conservatives saying this
this is leftists this is even cnn aaron
burnett on cnn
came out swinging and you don't you
don't often hear this from a left-wing
channel she said
but it's so obvious that you can't deny
it just wait a second
these these guys have been changing the
rules day by day by day and it's not
really based on the science they're even
changing the principles of what they're
talking about
where is the credibility what cdc needs
to say
is clearly that if you are not
vaccinated you must get vaccinated
and you must mask up but to do that they
had to basically tell the
uh vaccinated to manage so i understand
what you're saying
but i also take a step back here and i
say okay first they said
and science and and information can
change right but we all remember
at the very beginning here mask up even
if you're vaccinated because you could
spread it and then the yeah
guess what you can't spread it and now
oh my gosh now you can
maybe spread it and they're making the
change to the masking guidance based on
unpublished data but it shows that
vaccinated and
unvaccinated people infected by the
delta variant can have the same viral
road
viral load so so after changing it for
maybe you can spread it
you definitely can't maybe you can but
it's really rare they're telling you
it's really rare but you have the same
viral load i mean dr weiner it's really
confusing
and it does beg the question of do they
really know
or do they know things they're not
sharing us sharing with us i mean it's a
credibility question isn't it we don't
even know what rare means
preach sister i love it i'm sorry that
aaron burnett is going to lose her
facebook page i'm sorry that cnn is
going to lose its facebook page right
probably not probably there's going to
be different rules applied to people on
the left than people on the right
but she's making a very important point
and it's not just pointing out that
these guys have no credibility and
fouchy should be banished to saint
helena which obviously he should
she's she's making this point on data
which i think is actually even bigger
than the vaccines
bigger than kovit and it's it's kind of
a systemic
society-wide problem we are told
to trust these genius eggheads based on
data that very often
we can't see listen you you
pros you idiots we have information
that you don't have so just trust us
okay can we see the information
no but why not you idiot you can't you
don't know
you can't understand the information
it's a power
disparity that pervades not just the
public health
establishment it's the whole culture and
it's especially true
of big tech there's a terrific new book
that i'm reading right now called the
age of surveillance capitalism by
shoshana zubov we'll have to get her on
the show to talk about it
it's a straightforward study of how the
big tech giants
masked all of their control and what
that means is a major shift in the
economy
yeah the industrial revolution in the
19th century in the managerial
revolution in the 20th century
and now she has identified this
information revolution that
obviously is taking place and
increasingly what we are told is no you
you don't have the data
we have the data data are king data are
the most valuable commodities this is
why all of the services that you love to
use and enjoy
are free not all of them but a great
many of them facebook twitter google
search
youtube all they're free but they're not
really free you're paying you're paying
with your data
and you're paying with your privacy and
even through not just the searches you
make but the way in which you make
searches the time of day where you are
your your location
the the devices you're using every
people you're around
all of those are behavioral surplus
data that can form a profile of you
whereby these
people who are usually unelected in
almost all cases unelected
they probably know more about you than
your wife does they probably know more
about you
than you do and that is a power
disparity
that is completely unacceptable in a
self-governing republic
whether the people with the info with
the whether the people with the power
are wearing lab coats like fauci
or whether they're in silicon valley
even less accountability
and what is the response to all of this
when people
say this is too much guys this you are
wielding power in a way that is too
arbitrary and capricious you gotta cut
this out
the response from nancy pelosi is to
call
her colleague the house minority leader
kevin mccarthy
to call him a [ __ ] is
kevin mccarthy a [ __ ] and if so why
i said earlier in my comments science
science science and science
on almost every subject that you can
name science is the answer
whether it's the climate crisis whether
it's a health crisis
what it whether it's our preeminence
in the world in technology science
science science science
uh to say that wearing a mask
is not based on science i think is is
not
wise and that was my comment and that's
all i'm going to say about that
we make fun of people on this show like
the way that we make fun of the
scientistic left is by saying that all
they ever do is science science beep bop
beep beep boop science science science
and then she just
literally did that she literally just
science science science science science
science to say that the masks
uh are are not based on science that's
not wise
we've played the clip too many times on
the show so i'm not gonna play anymore
and i guess facebook won't even let me
play dr fauci anymore where dr fauci
says don't wear the masks they don't
help
so because then he changed his mind and
so that's the science that we
have to follow but i think it proves my
point again not on the masks but on
the science that is not
a serious answer and you'll notice that
as the science
get quote unquote capital s trademark
over the e is that gets sketchier
the science worshipers get more and more
aggressive
and so pelosi now uses this vulgar
language calls her
her colleague and [ __ ]
this is a an idolization
of the science is something that is
totally divorced from what science i
mean what
the scientific method is a method of
material inquiry whereby
you you make certain narrow predictions
and then you test them in the in the
physical world
science is the handmaiden of philosophy
philosophy is the handmaiden of theology
material science is just one aspect of
knowledge
science you can see the problem because
the word derives from the latin word for
all of knowledge and so
as we've made science this narrower
narrower pursuit we're also
pretending that this material inquiry
describes the entire world and obviously
it does not
nowhere in the constitution does it say
we the people in order to form a more
perfect union
uh are going to give dr fauci all the
power and follow the science that's not
what it says at all
there are many considerations that have
gone into the
way that our society is run some of
those involve the natural world some of
those
involve philosophy some of those involve
religion the religious premises of this
country
things like natural rights some of those
involve
geographic matters right there there is
a whole lot more here at stake
than just dr fauci and it's it's ironic
because the
the the less reliable the science
becomes the more the scientists
contradict themselves
the more people like pelosi double down
but it is not just science it is
moroccan i think
to a heretical religion remember we
played this wacky tick tock video last
week
where it was some young person
describing the difference between an
aromantic person
and an asexual person and that these are
different things or something well now
there's another
professor on tick tock a professor of
tick tock who has come out and said no
they're different but they're actually
they're actually the same and try to
understand it
next up we have ace flux
so ace flux is your person uh they're
going to fluctuate between
asexuality and allosexual so like
uh it's your person that one day they
could be like
fully asexual and then the next it could
totally change
so this is a person whose sexuality is
gonna fluctuate
on a daily basis one day they could have
crushes on somebody
one day they could be sexually attracted
to somebody
in some form or degree and the next day
they could be completely just
not interested not wanting anything to
do with so this
is your person that's gonna be asexual
one day
in some form or degree of sexual the
next i think that's really interesting
that's very
cool and uh i love learning about these
things as i go along so if you know
anybody who's on the ace flux or
anything
please tag them let them know share it
like comment thank you so you
first of all this this gal is just
describing everybody it's like yeah and
some days people are more
sexually inclined than others so oh
really wow i guess i'm that special
thing now i'm an ace or aloe or whatever
but you might say michael that's just
some sort of wacky tick tock video
that's going viral
the scientists are backing this stuff up
there was a medical school professor
yesterday we talked about them on the
show
at a prominent medical school in the
university of california system
who apologized to his students for for
saying the phrase pregnant women because
it's suggested that only women can
become pregnant
the kooky tick tock stuff is being
adopted by
the scientists because it's there's
nothing
scientific about it it's just a
heretical religion and anyone can take
part in a heretical religion and these
people don't
they don't even know what they don't
know they don't even know that they're
making philosophical and religious
claims when they pretend that
it's just all about the natural material
world and we can't question any of that
because if we do
we could easily be booted out of the
public square
you might call this an authoritarian
moment
well that's the title of ben's new book
it's the slogan for my
upcoming political campaign sometime in
the next few years the authoritarian
moment is available at barnes noble
amazon or any other major bookseller
you can get your copy now you can also
pick up an autographed copy for just
thirty dollars at dailywire.com
ben you can leave a five-star review to
help amplify conservative voices it's a
great book to order
after you order speechless controlling
words controlling minds my number one
national best-selling book
which is i think very much the topic of
today's show
after facebook sent out these new
guidelines also if you've ever thought
that it would be cool to travel on the
daily wires dime to our studios in
nashville
to smoke a cigar with all of us then you
might just be in luck
if you're not a member yet head to
dailywire.com
subscribe use code backstage to get 25
off your new membership
and be automatically entered to win two
tickets to lounge with the daily wire
legends
backstage who writes this stuff we're
legends i'll take it that's fine
that's not all you get to take home a
signed copy of my newest book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
so head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe with code backstage you get 25
off your membership and a chance to win
the ultimate backstage experience we'll
be back with a lot more
i learned so much on tick tock the tick
tock
really has its finger on the pulse of
the zeitgeist
there was a video another video that
went viral on tick tock
of a woman describing a very sad
state of mind but but it's an idea it's
an ideology that
is actually somewhat pervasive i've even
heard some of my friends talk about this
people who will not have children
because they're afraid
of global warming when people ask me if
i'm going to like
have kids i'm like i don't know because
the ocean was on fire last week and i'll
never be rich enough to send
my kids to another planet so it's kind
of an ethical dilemma for me
okay so maybe this gal's joking who
knows maybe she'll wise up and have kids
or something like that
but what what she is describing i have
had friends of mine say in earnest that
because of global warming
because of the sun monster because of
the 99.7
or whatever of scientists assuring that
the world is going to end in two years
ago
or whatever they say it was britain's
prince charles actually said the world
would already have ended
he predicted that he said we have 18
months then that was
a few years ago now i think aoc still
has eight or nine years left on her
prediction
but there have been many other past
predictions by by scientists notably
paul ehrlich from stanford who said that
the world is going to descend into mass
famine
because of the population bomb and
overpopulation he predicted that
that would happen certainly within 10 or
20 years and there was no way out of it
and we needed forced sterilization and
contraception and abortion as a result
to in any way head this thing off since
that time the world population has
doubled and malnutrition is at an
all-time low people are fatter than they
ever have been
before so the science totally wrong of
course and
there have been people who are choosing
not to have children because of these
factors
i mean you can just look at the birth
rate by the way we've had below
replacement birth rate
for a very long time in this country and
we're hitting new lows every single year
some of that might be because of
economic factors but i think a lot of
that is because of social and religious
factors
including the religion of
environmentalism which says that
human beings are blights upon the earth
and if we only wiped ourselves out it
would be
eden again
when people tell you oh it's just some
wacky tick tock oh it's just some wacky
video oh ignore that kind of stuff this
is being backed up by very prominent
scientists and they don't put it in
quite as clever a way
but the paul ehrlich's of the world the
people predicting imminent destruction
people telling you eat less move less do
less
have fewer children consume less they
are
they are real scientists and uh and
they're having an effect on the culture
which you're seeing on tick tock
which brings us it brings us to cuba
the cuba issue there have been a great
many people
on the right saying that we need to go
free cuba this is the chance it's been
the official policy of the united states
for 60 years ever since
castro took power and this is our chance
they're riders and
not rioters actual protesters in the
streets and i'm so used to protesters
actually being rioters that i forget
that when they're real protesters
they're not always rioting
and they're going out they're waving the
american flag and they're yelling
libertad
and so a number of conservatives are
saying send in the marines
but then there's another side of the
debate
which is saying america is collapsing
we're losing
all of our rights the economy is in free
fall inflation is going through the roof
we don't even have a southern border
anymore
now is not the time to be engaging in
foreign adventurism you know we've got
to get our own house in order before
we go and spread democracy abroad and
what would we be spreading what is the
american conception of libertad right
now
what's the american conception of
freedom is it the traditional conception
of freedom in america you know for for
god and for country going in
and apple pie and uh you know washington
and
jefferson and adams or is it a row aloe
pansexual you know trans the kids and
cultivate racial grievance everywhere
what is it hold on cubans
hold on havana we're coming we're coming
in to trans your kids don't worry
freedom's on the way is that because in
that case probably it's better if we
stick
stick here and contain the poison of
wokeness macron the the
president of france no conservative by
any means france not a conservative
country by any stretch of the
imagination
france is saying that wokeness isn't in
poisonous ideology
and they are going to make it a priority
of the government to keep it out of
france
so i think there's this other reaction
on the side of conservatives who they
say
we got to get get our house in order
first
so which is the right well they're both
right communism is
evil and it would be good to free cuba
and we shouldn't downplay the evils of
the castro regime
and we shouldn't fall into this this
you know way of of conflating communism
with whatever we're living through right
now
and say well maybe cuban communism is
not so bad no communism is an evil
wicked ideology i mean as as many popes
have condemned it it's a pest
a plague it steals the very gospel
itself as whitaker chambers says it's
the
alternative faith of mankind that began
in the garden when the serpent told evie
shall be his god so it's really evil
stuff and surely the
castro regime or what remains of it
should be should be ousted
but it's also true that we've got a lot
of ideological poison flowing around our
country right now
and we will not be able to effectively
project
a good and just vision of american power
abroad if we don't
fix our country and if we don't banish
fouchy to say helena and if we don't
take power back from the goons and the
thugs not only in the government and the
federal bureaucracy
but in the blob in the big tech
companies
in the corporate media companies if we
don't take our power back
and if we don't insist upon some
standards and if we don't
stop transiting the kids and if we don't
if we don't stop
pushing this racial ideological poison
in schools then we
we will not be able to free cuba we no
one wants to do it no american
not no american but very very few
americans have any appetite right now to
send the marines to havana
very few americans have any appetite
right now to send troops to taiwan to
protect it for instance from the
predations of china
because we don't even know what we're
projecting what is it what's our vision
what's our vision of the good
this is a problem that especially
conservatives have had for a long time
the leftist vision is clear destroy
everything whatever existed in america
it's bad topple every statue
tear down every institution what's the
conservative vision
cut taxes some more that's all that's
all we've had since the fall of the
berlin wall that's the only
unifying conservative vision it's cut
taxes a little bit more
that ain't enough that ain't going to
free cuba it ain't going to free taiwan
it ain't going to free the united states
the country has gone
mad you know i we played yesterday the
uh
that uh drama queen adam kinzinger the
liberal republican who
who had a little prick in his pocket i
think and
you know poked himself in in the leg
with a pin
or something and uh and made himself cry
when he talked about the january 6th
insurrection never mind blm forget about
that they burned a federal courthouse
not a big deal no no only the
the horn man and the podium theft and
whatever
we forgot to cover another drama queen
adam that would be the democrat
adam schiff who also musted mustard
tears
for that horrid the worst day in
american history
officer thank you um i believe in this
country
and i believe in it because of people
like you
uh who understand what the flag means
and what our constitution means and risk
their lives to defend it
i'd like to think uh as amanda gorman
so eloquently said that we're not broken
we're just unfinished
because if we're no longer committed to
a peaceful transfer of power
after our elections uh if our side
doesn't win then god help us
we deem elections illegitimate merely
because they didn't go our way
rather than trying to do better the next
time god help us
and if we're so driven by bigotry and
hate that we attack our fellow citizens
as traitors
if they're born another country or they
don't look like us
and
god help us
if we deal elections illegitimate like
i adam schiff led the democrats to do
for four years because i didn't believe
that the 2016 election was above board
and then so i tried to impeach the
president he led the impeachment this
guy
if because they didn't go our way
god help us god help us no one is
questioning
the election of 2020 because it didn't
go our way
democrats did question the election of
2016 because it didn't go their way they
had no
they had no argument as to why as to why
they lost that election so they just
made a bunch of stuff up he colluded
with the russians or the ukrainians or
whatever it didn't work out
in 2020 the people who are questioning
that election
are doing so not because it didn't go
our way but because democrats got rid of
virtually every election integrity
measure in the weeks before the election
and they changed many of the rules and
in some cases they violated state
constitutions
in how the election was conducted
notably in pennsylvania
that's why it's not because it didn't go
our way it's because you all
changed the rules and got rid of the
election integrity measures that even
barack obama a few years ago said were
very important measures
to to ensure the legitimacy of our
elections that's why
but you can't answer that shift and so
you're going to cry your crocodile tears
they have to make january 6th a big deal
because they need to keep everyone in a
state of
panic that the country is about to be
taken over our democracy our who took
over our democracy
who wields the power in this country is
it the conservatives
i don't think so aoc took this a step
further
so remember aoc said she was afraid that
she was going to die
on january 6 and she was so close to
death
and then it later turned out she wasn't
even in the capital she was down the
street in her office building
and she said she heard people knocking
on the door and this was and they were
going to come get her it turned out it
was a cop that was there to protect her
and so all of these things came out and
then she kept quiet for a while about
january 6.
now she's saying now she's saying that
she was in fear not just that she would
be killed
but that she would be raped as well that
attack on the capital
you know white supremacy and patriarchy
are very linked in a lot of ways there's
a lot of
sexualizing of that violence
and um i didn't think that i was just
going
to be killed i thought other things were
going to happen to me as well
so what sounds like what you're telling
me right now is that you didn't
only think that you were going to die
you thought you were going to be raped
yeah the mainstream media are reporting
on
aoc's rape fantasies from
the the capitol hill riot where she
wasn't even
in the building they are reporting on
that
as though it were fact because because
notice what
none of them lied in that clip the the
quote-unquote
interview or you know a quote-unquote
journalist and aoc
they didn't lie hey look aoc was never
anywhere close to being
killed she was never anywhere close to
being raped she was never anywhere close
to being harmed at all
but she's not claiming that she was
she's claiming that she felt
like she could be she's claiming that
she had a fantasy she's claiming that
she had a delusion
that she would be harmed and raped and
and
murdered and and then the interviewer
says
so you and you felt like that wow okay
well okay that's a fact i guess
for all the fact checkers out there that
that is a fact but her feeling was
delusional
and those fantas the leftist fantasy
about the country
is now fact incontrovertible
january 6 was the worst attack in our
country in the history
of of the entire nation right it was the
worst attack since 1812 they say and we
went through on the show yesterday
the many many other far more deadly
and dangerous attacks on our political
process in just the last
few decades in just the last few years
doesn't matter
that's out you are the fantasies that
the left has
about about the political process
about the virus about the necessary
measures to lock down about the way that
our constitutional system works
those fantasies are for all intents and
purposes
the practical reality of our country
because they've got the power
they wield all of the institutions
and so that's where we are
you're seeing this play out not just
at the bureaucracy not just in the big
tech oligarchs
not just in among the elected
representatives who are now
required to mask up at the capitol again
even though virtually all of them have
vaccines not just on the january 6
commission
you're seeing it at the olympics and i
think this is what
is driving people so
i'm not going to say it's driving them
crazy it's what what is really
frustrating people
about the question of simone biles this
olympian who is apparently quite
accomplished just deciding she doesn't
feel like
competing anymore and so she's going to
just going to focus on her because it's
not about america it's about her
it's the delusion that people are upset
about
so simone biles we talked about it
yesterday on the show simone biles this
athlete that i had never heard of until
two nights ago because i don't watch the
olympics and i don't really care and
it's no skin off my nose
simone biles starts to compete she takes
a spot on the olympic team and then she
says no i don't feel like it i'm not
having fun anymore it's not and now
now they're spinning it and they're
saying well it's because she was in
great danger
it's because she could have died or
they're trying to make up all but that's
not what simone bile said simon bile
said yeah i'm just not feeling it it's
not fun i got i'm gonna focus on me
physically i'm fine but emotionally i'm
not there and so
you know i'm just going to get into a
better head space and sorry sorry
america i'm going to let you down
now one of simone biles's teammates is
coming out and defending her
because for a while there were some
people who said you know simone biles is
really letting her
team down but then the teammate comes
out and says
quote i've never been prouder to be a
part of such an amazing team with an
amazing group of girls
we stepped up when we needed to and did
this for ourselves
we do not owe anyone a gold medal we are
winners
in our hearts
i'm glad this girl is a winner in her
heart i would prefer that she be a
winner in reality
because she does not owe anyone a gold
medal that's true but she does owe
us the american people something she
owes us
trying she owes us competing
we had it and so does simone biles we
had a deal
when when you go to the olympics
you are representing the country we the
american people including me i don't
care about the olympics i almost never
watch it
but including me we all of the
countrymen we send you there
to represent us and to go beat all the
other countries and bring
medals home to the united states
hopefully gold medals
and i'm not saying that you i'm not i'm
not like saddam hussein where if you
don't bring a gold medal home we're
going to torture you or something i'm
not saying you owe us
to win but you do owe us to try you did
you
you might be doing this for yourselves
but you should not be yes it is about
individual
athletic excellence yes it's about the
team's athletic excellence
but ultimately that is for a purpose
which is the glory of your country
and so you're doing it in part for
yourself but really you should be doing
this
for your country we are winners in our
hearts
that and a buck 50 will get you a cup of
coffee and i don't even mean to beat up
on this girl
what what's her name i don't even know
her name and i don't even mean to beat
up on simone biles
i really don't i mean to identify
a very harmful delusion
that we're all operating under namely
that delusion is reality i
i mean to identify this this radical
subjectivism
that we're all living under that there
is no objective reality there is no duty
it's all just about me me me and my own
feelings and my own self-identity
and how and one day what is the kid on
tick-tock
i'm an a-ro halo asex and it's all just
about
me me me there there are more things
than you a man wrapped up in himself
makes a small package indeed there is an
objective reality the words that we use
refer
to reality that's the only way we can
communicate and have self-government
there is a faculty of reason there is
a moral conscience you do have access to
it there is a transcendent moral order
there is good and bad and right and
wrong and true and false we can discern
between those things
if we can't self-government's not
possible and
increasingly that's the case speaking of
young people playing games
gavin newsom the beleaguered
governor of california some call him
nussolini some call him governor bateman
he loves huey lewis in the news gavin
newsom just got in trouble because we're
told
now that everyone's got a mask up and
all the kids especially have to mask up
and gavin newsom sent his kids to a
summer camp where they're not requiring
the kids to wear masks
because they're sensible and this just
came out that gavin newsom once again is
playing by a different set of rules than
he's forcing everyone else to play by
this reminds us of when gavin newsom
forced the businesses to close down and
restaurants to shut down
and everyone to wear masks and then they
caught gavin newsom at the french
laundry a michelin rated restaurant
shoulder to shoulder with his friends in
a huge dinner party no one wearing masks
because none of these people actually
care about it
they just want you to care about it none
of these people who are enforcing the
rules be they at facebook
or the cdc or the governor's governor's
office in
california none of them are particularly
meticulous about these things but it's
about the imposition of the rules on you
so he got caught he sent his kids to a
camp where they don't play by the rules
that he says everyone else needs to play
by
and so what did he do he's trying to
spin it he's saying he's
shocked to learn that the kids aren't
wearing masks and this is so terrible
and he pulled his kids out of the camp
ostensibly because he's worried about
the virus spread that's the new spin
coming out of newsome's office
this is a rotten thing to do on every
level it's a rotten thing
to impose these rules on kids
to the facebook overlords i'm not i'm
not even
i would never question the efficacy of
masks
i would never quote dr fauci but that's
not that's not even what i'm saying it's
a rotten thing
as a political matter it's a personal
matter it's a rotten thing to force kids
to do this stuff
and so not only is gavin newsom
now that he got caught insisting that
all the kids do he's also pulling his
kids out of the camp that's a rotten
thing to do just to save your own
political hide
terrible terrible stuff i do want to end
though on a note of a bit of hope
which is you know there's this case
working its way up the supreme court
it's the dobbs
case and the dobbs case seeks to
overturn roe versus wade and planned
parenthood vkc the two preposterous
court decisions that invented a
constitutional right to abortion
so this case is going to be heard that
it's going to be decided
this term it's it's worth pointing out
that the law at stake in the dobbs case
is this law that says that you can't get
an abortion after 15 weeks at 15 weeks
the baby can suck his thumb
in the mother's womb okay 15 weeks this
thing
looks like a baby seems like a baby is
obviously is obviously a baby
that law would not be as the left says a
return to the horrible barbaric dark
ages where
women are not allowed to do that law
would bring
united states abortion policy back into
line
with europe europe which is so far to
the left of
of america on so many issues europe
has this abortion policy in some cases a
more restrictive abortion policy
than even would be in place given the
mississippi law
the united states is absolutely barbaric
on the question of abortion we are the
outlier
we when you look at our abortion laws
how they compare around the world
our abortion laws are on par with canada
canada has
similarly barbaric abortion laws but
then the other countries that we're in
line with
are china and north korea okay
the rest of the civilized world has the
mississippi law or things that are even
more restrictive and it brings up this
question
what are we exporting when the marines
are going to land it at havana well
actually they have horrible abortion
laws there too because they're
communists but when we're talking about
projecting american power around the
world
what are we exporting what do we stand
for what is it
if we i'm all for projecting a good
wonderful
culture and politics around the world we
need to get ours in order first
there are concrete steps that we can
that we can undertake to do it but that
will
require some courage and clarity and
vision i'm michael knowles this michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico associate producer justine
turley
audio mixer mike coromina and hair and
makeup by nika geneva
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. john vickley here editor-in-chief
of daily wire
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire on today's show the biden
administration moves to impose
federal vaccine mandates canadian
churches are targeted by arsonists
and the supreme court agrees to hear a
case that could impact roe v
wade join us and get the facts first on
the news you need to know
with our show morning wire